[Musique]
à droite républicaine à un avenir notre
famille politique celle des républicains
nous avons en véritable avenir et un
message à portée envers les françaises
et les français depuis plusieurs
semaines autour de christian jacob notre
président l'équipe dirigeante rebâti
cette belle famille politique de la
droite républicaine
mais nous avons aujourd'hui besoin de
vous nous ne reprendrons pas la droite
sans un grand mouvement populaire
nous avons besoin de vos adhésion nous
avons besoin que chacune et chacun
d'entre vous vous rejoignez vous nous
apportiez votre force militante celle
qui a toujours fait nos victoires
passées et qui fera une réussite à venir
aujourd'hui je vous lance cet appel cet
appel à la mobilisation cet appel au
soutien renforcé le travail que nous
avons engagées préparer nous préparons
nous ensemble à construire l'avenir ré
adhérer ou adhérer aux républicains
[Musique]